I forgot how much anticipation and sort
of weirdness around the mornings there
are everybody's in their own little
world people aren't really talking to
each other it's not nervous laughter and
then you get through that first run and
then everybody just opens up and
everybody just has this big smile on
their face joking around again
I haven't been on a snowboard to get
about 12 15 years so I took a lesson
today I went out with my instructor Cara
who was awesome and taught me everything
that I needed enduro we started at zero
and sort of accelerated towards about 40
we finished up after I think about four
hours and I'm totally wiped but I feel
really confident i was doing full runs
without falling down and i'm really
looking forward to going back out again
tomorrow